This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Not long ago, I found myself in a subterranean labyrinth below the streets of Washington, DC. I'd come and search of clues. So here we are in Deck 50 in the Stacks of the Library of Congress. I'm opening a door that's marked Door 20. My guide is a tall, shaggy man named Steve Winick. He looks a lot like Hagrid from Harry Potter, which seems about right for somebody with
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。不久前，我发现自己身处华盛顿特区街道下方的一座地下迷宫中。我是来寻找线索的。现在我们位于国会图书馆书库的50号架区。我正打开标有20号门的门。我的向导是一位名叫史蒂夫·威尼克的身材高大、毛发蓬乱的男子。他看起来很像《哈利·波特》里的海格，对于一个拥有
a title of folklorist. Steve has already let me through a maze of low-ceiling stacks across a small bridge and into a tiny elevator where the flow numbers go up as we go down. But now we've arrived. In here, we find row upon row of collection boxes on the shelves, and I'm looking for this collection, which is number AFC 1979-008. Steve pulls from the shelf a cardboard box. Nobody's really used this collection very much, so it's simply, you know, been there waiting
民俗学家头衔的人来说，这似乎很贴切。史蒂夫已经带我穿过了一片低矮书架组成的迷宫，穿过一座小桥，进入了一部小电梯，电梯里的楼层数字随着我们的下降而增加。但现在我们到了。在这里，我们发现书架上摆放着一排排的收藏盒，我正在寻找这个编号为AFC 1979-008的收藏。史蒂夫从书架上取下一个纸板箱。真的没几个人用过这个收藏，所以它只是，你知道，一直待在那里等着
for you, really. The author of this collection is Richard Riley Shepard, a small time crook and con man who died in 2009. I've been tracking Riley Shepard for a few months. My assumption is that there's nothing of significance in the box. But I'm about to discover that the story I thought I was reporting is not the story I am reporting. The story that is about one fold before me is a story of obsession. one fall before me is a story of obsession. It's power, it's beauty, and it's costs. This week on Hidden Brain we explore the peculiar tale of Riley Shepard, a musician and writer who spend decades on a single grand project. Whether that project was a great quest or a great folly, that is for you to decide.
你，真的。这个收藏的作者是理查德·莱利·谢泼德，一个在2009年去世的小骗子和诈骗犯。我追踪莱利·谢泼德已经几个月了。我的假设是盒子里没什么重要的东西。但我即将发现，我以为我在报道的故事并不是我正在报道的故事。在我面前展开的故事是一个关于痴迷的故事。它有力量，有美感，也有代价。本周在《Hidden Brain》中，我们将探索莱利·谢泼德的奇特故事，他是一位音乐家和作家，花了数十年时间完成了一个宏大的项目。那个项目究竟是一次伟大的探索还是一场巨大的愚行，这由你来决定。
He was a genius, I think. He just was a compulsive liar. Quite a master. He was getting out of town before he was being tarting together. I haven't got time for that. I gotta get this done. They all hate you, my god. I should forgive them. Albert Riley, Joe Graham, what do you do? I stumbled onto the story as I was contemplating an episode not about obsession, but about fallen
我认为他是个天才。他只是个强迫性撒谎者。相当厉害。他在被赶出城之前就离开了。我没时间处理那个。我得把这个做完。他们都恨你，天哪。我应该原谅他们。阿尔伯特·莱利，乔·格雷厄姆，你该怎么办？我偶然发现了这个故事，当时我正在构思一集关于堕落英雄而不是痴迷的故事。
heroes. I'd asked hidden brain listeners to share examples from their own lives. One of the messages, I hope I did this right, was from Stasha Shepard Silverman. She said her fallen hero was her dad, Riley Shepard, whom she still loved. I want to say that I had a great relationship with my father. He was totally cool in many ways and a great cook. When we talk, Stasha tells me that as a young girl, she idolized her dad.
我曾请《Hidden Brain》的听众分享他们自己生活中的例子。其中一条信息，希望我没弄错，来自斯塔莎·谢泼德·西尔弗曼。她说她的堕落英雄是她的父亲莱利·谢泼德，她至今仍爱着他。我想说我和我父亲的关系很好。他在很多方面都很酷，而且是个很棒的厨师。当我们交谈时，斯塔莎告诉我，作为一个小女孩，她崇拜她的父亲。
She has memories of those days that feel like tiny, sparkling gems. My earliest memory of my dad is sitting on his lap and him smoking his cigar, and he would make cigar smoke rings for me. Stasha would watch them, transfixed, as they rose in the air before her. I thought the smoke rings were magical.
她对那些日子的记忆就像一颗颗闪闪发光的小宝石。我对我父亲最早的记忆是坐在他的膝盖上，他抽着雪茄，他会为我吐出雪茄烟圈。斯塔莎会目不转睛地看着它们，看着它们在自己面前升入空中。我觉得那些烟圈很神奇。
There was a lot that was magical for Stasha back then. She still remembers their little apartment in Hollywood, with the Symees cat and the cat hair and the hardwood floors. She remembers how much she loved that her dad was around all the time. He didn't have a regular job and he would sit in the middle of the living room usually, wherever we lived, and he would type. So he was working on things. He was working on, I didn't know what,
那时对斯塔莎来说，有很多东西都很神奇。她仍然记得他们在好莱坞的小公寓，有暹罗猫、猫毛和硬木地板。她记得她有多喜欢父亲一直陪在身边。他没有固定的工作，通常会坐在客厅中央，无论我们住在哪里，他都会打字。所以他在做一些事情。他在做，我不知道是什么，
but I would sit under his desk sometimes while he typed away and we would talk in between the pages and he would tell me things about show business. They were in their own little bubble, Riley in his late 50s and his little daughter, typing, talking, just being together. Sometimes if Riley had a little daughter, typing, talking, just being together. Sometimes, if Riley had a little money, he'd take Starshire out to eat at their favorite Hollywood hotspot, a restaurant called the Brown Derby.
但我有时会坐在他的书桌下，听着他打字，我们在页面之间交谈，他会告诉我一些关于演艺圈的事情。他们生活在自己的小泡沫里，50多岁的莱利和他的小女儿，打字、聊天，只是在一起。有时，如果莱利有一点钱，他会带斯塔莎去他们最喜欢的餐厅吃饭，那是一家叫“棕色德比”的餐厅。
It was a place where Riley could drop shoulders with famous people, charm them with his warm southern accent, and impress his daughter on their way home. You know, the Hollywood stars were all around us. We could walk up the street and my father would tell me about movie stars when we walked. He seemed to know everything. Stasha was certain that her dad was something of a star himself. Sometimes he tell her about his musical career as a successful promoter, singer and songwriter. Occasionally, he might even sing the song, his song.
那是一个莱利可以与名人并肩，用他温暖的南方口音吸引他们，并在回家路上给女儿留下深刻印象的地方。你知道，好莱坞明星就在我们周围。我们可以走在街上，我父亲会在我们走路时告诉我关于电影明星的事。他似乎什么都知道。斯塔莎确信她的父亲自己也是个明星。有时他会告诉她他作为成功的推广人、歌手和词曲作者的音乐生涯。偶尔，他甚至会唱那首歌，他的歌。
He told me and he told everyone that he wrote the song Blue Christmas. He told me and he told everyone that he wrote the song Blue Christmas. It wasn't true. Billy Hayes and Jay Johnson wrote Blue Christmas. The person who made it famous? Elvis. If Riley had written Blue Christmas, money might not have been so tight for the family. I was told constantly that we were artists and that there were artists and there were ordinary people and we were artists. Stascha eventually learned about her dad's most important artistic endeavor, not a song, but a writing project. The encyclopedia of folk music.
他告诉我，也告诉所有人，他写了《蓝色圣诞节》这首歌。那不是真的。比利·海耶斯和杰伊·约翰逊写了《蓝色圣诞节》。让它出名的人？猫王。如果莱利写了《蓝色圣诞节》，家里的经济可能就不会那么紧张了。我经常被告知我们是艺术家，有艺术家，也有普通人，而我们是艺术家。斯塔莎最终了解了她父亲最重要的艺术事业，不是一首歌，而是一个写作项目。民俗音乐百科全书。
And that was supposedly his life's work. And it was vast. I mean, there were boxes there, huge boxes of volumes of indexes and things he was working on in books. To fund its creation, Riley solicited money from investors, some of whom he convinced to pour thousands of dollars into the project. Sometimes investors and bill collectors would call to ask when they were going to get paid. He used to get on the phone with all kinds of people and say, you didn't get the check.
那据说是他毕生的心血。而且规模宏大。我的意思是，那里有盒子，巨大的装满索引卷宗的盒子，还有他正在研究的书籍。为了资助它的创作，莱利向投资者募集资金，其中一些人被他说服投入了数千美元。有时投资者和收债人会打电话来问他们什么时候能拿到钱。他过去常接各种人的电话，说，你没收到支票吗？
What? The post office, he would constantly rail against the post office. So as a little girl, I also became very militant against the post office. I also would rail against the post office. I also would rail against the post office. And if I had a pen pal or a friend that I was writing a letter to, I'd always write on the outside of the envelope, you better deliver this letter.
什么？邮局，他会不断地抨击邮局。所以作为一个小女孩，我也变得非常敌视邮局。我也会抨击邮局。如果我有笔友或朋友要写信，我总会在信封外面写上，你最好把这封信送到。
You know, I was like enraged with the post office that they wouldn't deliver letters because I just thought they're constantly throwing my dad under the bus and not mailing his checks. For many children, there is a moment when a curtain pulls back and parents are revealed for who they are, in perfect beings, with flaws and failings. But for Starscher, the father she saw when the curtain opened, was hard to recognize. It happened one day when she was 12, hanging out at home.
你知道，我对邮局不投递信件感到愤怒，因为我只是认为他们一直在陷害我父亲，不寄他的支票。对于许多孩子来说，有一个时刻，帷幕拉开，父母的真面目显露出来，他们是不完美的，有缺陷和失败。但对于斯塔莎来说，当帷幕拉开时，她看到的父亲很难辨认。那发生在她12岁的一天，在家里闲逛时。
And the phone rang. So I picked it up, I said hello. The caller demanded to speak to her dad. Starscher said he was out. His voice was shaking, and I could tell he was elderly. And he just sounded like a mean old man to me. He scared me. And he told me that my father took his life savings.
电话响了。所以我接了，我说你好。打电话的人要求和她父亲说话。斯塔莎说他出去了。他的声音在颤抖，我能听出他年纪很大。他听起来像个刻薄的老人。他吓坏了我。他告诉我，我父亲拿走了他毕生的积蓄。
The phone is in my ear, and he's saying, your father's a crook. Did you know that? Your father is a crook. In 1946, Riley Shepard released a cover of the hit song, Atomic Power. It was inspired by the bombings of Hiroshima and Nagasaki. Riley was a rising talent. He had dark, good looks, a soft southern twang, and the guitar skills to make a go of it. He signed with various labels. He seemed headed somewhere.
电话贴在我的耳朵上，他说，你父亲是个骗子。你知道吗？你父亲是个骗子。1946年，莱利·谢泼德发行了热门歌曲《原子能》的翻唱版。它的灵感来自广岛和长崎的爆炸。莱利是一位冉冉升起的人才。他长相英俊，带着柔和的南方口音，还有吉他技巧。他与多家唱片公司签约。他似乎前途无量。
But Riley Shepard never achieved stardom. Instead, his life took a series of detours. Music historian Kevin Coffey tracked Riley down about a decade ago. Riley at the time was 89. He would die a year later. Kevin was interested in preserving the stories of all-time country western performers. He thought Riley might be worth profiling. He played steel in one of your records.
但莱利·谢泼德从未获得明星地位。相反，他的人生经历了一系列曲折。音乐历史学家凯文·科菲大约十年前找到了莱利。莱利当时89岁。他一年后去世了。凯文有兴趣保存老牌乡村音乐表演者的故事。他认为莱利值得一写。他在你的一张唱片里弹过钢弦吉他。
The conversation they had over a crackly phone line was friendly and nostalgic and full of insider names. Most people wouldn't recognize. That is, the lowest life was played piano, really hard, really, yeah. Gradually, Kevin pieced together Riley's backstory. Richard Riley Shepard was born in a farm near Wilmington, North Carolina in 1918. He dropped out of school in the fifth grade and decided to try his luck at singing.
他们在嘈杂的电话线上进行的谈话很友好，充满怀旧感，还提到了大多数人认不出来的圈内人的名字。那是，最底层的生活是弹钢琴，真的很努力，真的，是的。渐渐地，凯文拼凑出了莱利的背景故事。理查德·莱利·谢泼德于1918年出生在北卡罗来纳州威尔明顿附近的一个农场。他在五年级时辍学，决定去尝试唱歌。
It was a heady time for music in the region, groups like the Maynars mountaineers were popularizing what was then called Hilbilly Music. just to face it through. Pleasure's in my home, my farm beyond the blues. There are many friends who help me and have gone before, and I can't be there home and as well anymore. Riley started out playing songs and minstrel shows. Soon he told Kevin he was getting gigs with hillbilly groups like the Dixie Reelers. By the early 1940s, Riley had moved to Chicago. He toured with other hillbilly musicians and did comedy and acting work.
那是该地区音乐的一个激动人心的时代，像梅纳斯登山者这样的团体正在推广当时所谓的“乡巴佬音乐”。莱利开始在吟游诗人表演中演唱歌曲。很快，他告诉凯文，他开始在像“迪克西卷轴者”这样的乡巴佬团体中获得演出机会。到1940年代初，莱利搬到了芝加哥。他与其他乡巴佬音乐家一起巡演，并从事喜剧和表演工作。
He also began cultivating his image as a cowboy crooner. As he created this new persona, he gave himself a catchy moniker, the cowboy philosopher. Where did you come up with that with that? Because I know you were calling yourself the gum-up, whether you knock your head off with no dead head. Because I found an ad from way back in 1945 and you were already using it. That's then.
他还开始塑造自己作为牛仔歌手的形象。当他创造这个新角色时，他给自己起了一个朗朗上口的绰号，“牛仔哲学家”。你是怎么想出那个的？因为我知道你以前叫自己……因为我找到了1945年的一则广告，你已经在用了。那是当时。
She came up with that crap. To top off his fancy new title of philosopher, Riley grew a dashing moustache and began scheming up fresh ways to get into the spotlight. The cosmopolitan church presents Dr. Richard Riley Sheppard, Ph.D.D. This is Tasha again. A few years ago, she found one of the old flyers that advertised her dad's lectures. Dr. Richard Riley Shepard, author, historian, world traveler, philosopher, in a series of educational lectures.
她想出了那个废话。为了给他的新头衔“哲学家”锦上添花，莱利留了一撇时髦的胡子，并开始策划新的方式来进入聚光灯下。世界主义教堂呈现理查德·莱利·谢泼德博士，哲学博士。这是斯塔莎。几年前，她发现了其中一张宣传她父亲讲座的旧传单。理查德·莱利·谢泼德博士，作家、历史学家、世界旅行家、哲学家，举办一系列教育讲座。
The world traveler and philosopher was prepared to discuss a variety of important topics. Saturday, October 10, God, man, and society. Saturday, October 17, marriage, sex, Saturday, October 31, God, Man, and Saturday October 17th, Marriage, Sex, Saturday October 31st, Democracy and Capitalist. Saturday November 7th, Origin and Growth of Fascism. Even as he sought to make a name for himself with his educational lectures, Riley was still churning out songs at a frenzied pace, often releasing a new record every month. songs at a frenzied pace, often releasing a new record every month. But Kevin says, Riley wasn't reliable. He'd signed with one record label, and while his contract was still in force,
这位世界旅行家和哲学家准备讨论各种重要主题。10月10日星期六，上帝、人和社会。10月17日星期六，婚姻、性，10月31日星期六，上帝、人和社会。10月17日星期六，婚姻、性，10月31日星期六，民主和资本主义。11月7日星期六，法西斯主义的起源和发展。即使在他试图通过教育讲座成名时，莱利仍在疯狂地创作歌曲，通常每个月发行一张新唱片。但凯文说，莱利不可靠。他会与一家唱片公司签约，而在合同仍然有效时，
he'd signed with another. He'd often use different stage names or pseudonyms with different labels. Dickie Fri was one of the names I do. Dickie Fri, Dickie Fri, and that was all I did. For a time, Riley was able to make it all work, in part because he did have a little star power. He'd done well with atomic power, and later had another catchy tune titled Cowboy. I got me no home, I got me no wife, I've been the cowboy for all of my life. I guess I like being free. My house, my my saddle and me. Riley recorded it under the name Dixon Hall. I looked out the window and I saw a thing called Hall's closing, big sign.
他又会与另一家签约。他经常在不同的唱片公司使用不同的艺名或笔名。“迪基·弗里”是我知道的名字之一。迪基·弗里，迪基·弗里，这就是我所做的。有一段时间，莱利能够让这一切运转，部分原因是他确实有一点明星魅力。他在《原子能》上表现不错，后来又有一首朗朗上口的曲子叫《牛仔》。我没有家，我没有妻子，我一生都是牛仔。我想我喜欢自由。我的房子，我的马鞍和我。莱利以“迪克森·霍尔”的名字录制了它。我看向窗外，看到一个叫“霍尔关闭”的大招牌。
Our Dixon came in. This was our Dixon Hall. That's how they don't take. No wife ever got me, no. This was how Riley operated. He played fast and loose. He also worked as an agent, getting music labels to sign new artists.
我们的迪克森进来了。这就是我们的迪克森·霍尔。这就是他运作的方式。他行事草率。他还担任经纪人，让音乐公司签约新艺人。
You see, I tell him, what do you think a publisher is? He's just a businessman. He wouldn't know a hit song to crawl out from under his desk and get him under late. He sold songs to these executives with a combination of bluster and hype. This role allowed Riley to capitalize on one of his greatest strengths. He was a born salesman. He once boasted that he could have started his own religion. We get about Su City Su, which was written by Dick Thomas. Su City Su, the day he drew your hair is red, your eyes are blue.
你看，我告诉他，你认为出版商是什么？他只是个商人。他甚至不知道什么是热门歌曲。他用吹嘘和炒作的结合向这些高管推销歌曲。这个角色让莱利能够利用他最大的优势之一。他是个天生的推销员。他曾经吹嘘说他可以创立自己的宗教。我们得到了关于《苏城苏》的歌，那是迪克·托马斯写的。
I swapped my horse and dog for you. Recorded by him on a small label, and he brought it to me, and I said, if you do what I tell you, you'll make a lot of money. And he did. I got him $7,000 in advance, and $7.00 in copies. It's the biggest money I've ever paid for a hillbilly song. I bet. In those days.
我用我的马和狗换了你。由他在一家小唱片公司录制，他把它带给我，我说，如果你照我说的做，你会赚很多钱。他确实赚了。我给了他7000美元的预付款，还有7美元的版税。这是我为乡巴佬歌曲支付过的最大一笔钱。我敢打赌。在那些日子里。
Riley was also a hustler in his personal life, where the consequences of his actions were more serious. Marion Kiminek knows this well. She was adopted at birth. As an adult, she searched for and found her biological mother. From her, Marion learned that her father was Riley Shepard. Marion's mother had met him while working as an actress in Chicago. And she said it was very charming, very good looking. He played the guitar and he sang.
莱利在个人生活中也是个骗子，那里的后果更严重。玛丽恩·基米内克很清楚这一点。她出生时就被收养了。成年后，她寻找并找到了她的亲生母亲。从她那里，玛丽恩得知她的父亲是莱利·谢泼德。玛丽恩的母亲是在芝加哥当演员时认识他的。她说他非常有魅力，长得很好看。他弹吉他，唱歌。
And I guess she was kind of smitten with him and uh... She got pregnant. That she told Marion wasn't supposed to happen. He told her he was sterile. And for what I understand he told every woman he was with that he was sterile. The world will never know the reason. The reason why I said we're through. Whatever he'd achieved in the music industry, it was all winding down by the early 1960s. By then, Riley had picked up and moved on to the west coast. Yieldy high, or guilty high. to the west coast. He first went to Oregon and then to California. He told Kevin he gave
我想她有点迷恋他，而且……她怀孕了。她说那是不应该发生的。他告诉她他绝育了。据我所知，他告诉他交往的每个女人他都绝育了。世界永远不会知道原因。我为什么说我们完了的原因。无论他在音乐界取得了什么成就，到1960年代初，一切都在走下坡路。那时，莱利已经收拾行囊搬到了西海岸。
up the music business so he could turn his attention to a new project, an encyclopedia of folk music. But Kevin, things years of lying and cheating and breaking contracts had simply caught up with him. He made it sound like he did these moves for different purposes. I think usually he was getting out of town before he was being tart and feathered. It's perhaps fitting that the place Riley landed for the next chapter of his life was Hollywood. Tinseltown was shiny and bright and full of the kind of transformative stories that Riley loved. He arrived there with his common law wife and young daughter, Stascha. For a while, he thrived in his new role as Riley Shepard, family man.
他先去了俄勒冈州，然后去了加利福尼亚州。他告诉凯文他放弃了音乐事业，这样他就可以把注意力转向一个新项目，一部民俗音乐百科全书。但凯文认为，多年的撒谎、欺骗和违约行为已经让他付出了代价。他把这些举动说成是为了不同的目的。我认为通常他是在被赶出城之前就离开了。莱利为他人生下一章选择的地方是好莱坞，这或许很合适。丁塞尔镇闪闪发光，充满了莱利所钟爱的那种充满变数的故事。他带着他的同居妻子和年幼的女儿斯塔莎来到那里。有一段时间，他在“莱利·谢泼德，顾家男人”这个新角色中表现得很好。
But like most things in Riley's life, it didn't last. Your father is a crook. After all these years, Stasha still fixates on the memory of that old man's telephone call. Stascha says it was a turning point in her relationship with her father. That night, she confronted him. Right when he walked in the door, I was like, you know, screaming at him, you're a crook, you're a crook. And he looked at me like he turned white and he was shocked. And we argued, we fought.
但像莱利生活中的大多数事情一样，它并没有持续下去。“你父亲是个骗子。”多年后，斯塔莎仍然盯着那个老人打来的电话的记忆。斯塔莎说那是她与父亲关系的一个转折点。那天晚上，她与他对质。就在他走进门时，我像是在对他尖叫，你是个骗子，你是个骗子。他看着我，脸色苍白，他很震惊。我们争吵，我们打架。
I don't remember the exact words, but I remember he stormed out and he went out to his car and he sat there and smoked and he didn't come back inside for a long time. He would just, that's what he would do and he was mad, he would go out and he was carin' pout. But the next morning, Riley did what came naturally to him. He turned on the charm. He tried to smooth things over. He made stasha pancakes.
我不记得确切的话，但我记得他冲了出去，走到他的车里，坐在那里抽烟，很长一段时间没有回来。他就是那样，他会那样做，他很生气，他会出去。但第二天早上，莱利做了他自然而然会做的事。他开启了魅力攻势。他试图平息事态。他给斯塔莎做了煎饼。
He told her the encyclopedia was going to make a lot of money and that his investors would get paid. Stascha wanted to believe him. Well, you know, I loved my dad and he was very apologetic and sweet and you want to believe your parents and also he was very good at convincing. Stasha didn't know how much money her dad owed, but she got the sense he was constantly evading creditors. She tells one story of calling home to get a ride. And when my dad picked up the phone,
他告诉她百科全书会赚很多钱，他的投资者会得到报酬。斯塔莎想相信他。好吧，你知道，我爱我的父亲，他非常抱歉，很甜，你想相信你的父母，而且他非常擅长说服。斯塔莎不知道她父亲欠了多少钱，但她感觉到他一直在逃避债权人。她讲了一个打电话回家要求搭便车的故事。当我父亲接电话时，
he was pretending to be a Chinese man. He was pretending to be used this accent accent that like from breakfast at Tiffany's, that horrible, you know, was a Mickey Rooney. Anyway, terrible. And but I knew it was him. You know your father's voice. I'm like, dad. And he was like, hung up on me. like hung up on me. Riley took every shortcut he could to make a buck. For a time he wrote porn under the pseudonym Zachary Quill. One of his books, Glowing Heat. Stasha says her mother told her that Riley had worked out of formula. She said,
他在假装是一个中国人。他在假装用那种口音，就像《蒂凡尼的早餐》里那种可怕的，你知道，是米基·鲁尼。总之，太糟糕了。但我知道是他。你知道你父亲的声音。我说，爸爸。他就像，挂断了我的电话。莱利为了赚钱采取了每一个捷径。有一段时间，他以“扎卡里·奎尔”的笔名写色情作品。他的一本书，《炽热的热度》。斯塔莎说她母亲告诉她，莱利制定了一个公式。她说，
oh well dad used to get all these cheap novels and then he would write porn scenes and he would have typists insert the porn scenes in these crappy novels and resell them. This was Stasha's life. Things were always off-kilter, confusing. She remembers another time when they had to flee their house before the landlord came, probably because Riley hadn't paid the rent. We got in this rickety old truck with all our stuff jammed in it. And my father's encyclopedia of folk music was in there very carefully packed. Those were the biggest boxes that we took. And all our other stuff was just kind of strewn
哦，爸爸过去常买这些廉价小说，然后他会写色情场景，他会让打字员把色情场景插入这些烂小说中，然后转卖它们。这就是斯塔莎的生活。事情总是乱七八糟，令人困惑。她记得还有一次，他们在房东来之前不得不逃离他们的房子，可能是因为莱利没付房租。我们坐进这辆破旧的老卡车，里面塞满了我们的东西。我父亲的民俗音乐百科全书被非常小心地打包在里面。那是我们带走的最大盒子。而我们所有的其他东西只是散落在
in this truck, and it wasn't very well packed. And when we were driving down the highway, I remember that. So it was so weird. You know, people were pointing at us and trying to get our attention. And we were like, I mean, I remember my mother being like, wow, why are they waving at us? And then realizing, oh, our stuff is flying out. Like our slim belongings that we had paired down from selling almost everything else. Those things were flying out, not the encyclopedia folk music, but my clothes and what few things. By the late 1970s, the family had settled in Portoville, California, a town on the western edge of the Sierra Nevada mountains.
这辆卡车里，打包得不太好。当我们开车在高速公路上时，我记得那个。太奇怪了。你知道，人们指着我们，试图引起我们的注意。我记得我母亲说，哇，他们为什么要向我们挥手？然后意识到，哦，我们的东西飞出去了。就像我们卖掉几乎所有其他东西后剩下的微薄财产。那些东西飞出去了，不是民俗音乐百科全书，而是我的衣服和仅有的几样东西。到1970年代末，这家人定居在加利福尼亚州的波特维尔，一个位于内华达山脉西缘的小镇。
Riley spent his days working on his encyclopedia and to Stasha's mind, swindling everyone he could. It all ended when Stascha was 18. That year, 1983, Riley Shepard did what he had done many times before. He disappeared. He told my mother who he had been with for whatever 23 years that he was taking a short trip to Los Angeles. But when she woke up in the morning she realized that he had taken way more than what you would need for a short trip.
莱利每天都在研究他的百科全书，在斯塔莎看来，他在欺骗他能欺骗的所有人。这一切在斯塔莎18岁时结束了。那一年，1983年，莱利·谢泼德做了他以前做过很多次的事情。他失踪了。他告诉和我母亲在一起23年的她，他要去洛杉矶进行一次短途旅行。但当她早上醒来时，她意识到他带走的东西远不止短途旅行所需的。
And he never, he did not come back. For more than a year, Stasha had no idea where he was. Eventually she found him living about an hour away in Fresno. They reconnected, but everything had changed. She now saw him for exactly who he was. He glamorized the life of being a grifter. He glamorized the life of being a con man. That's what I understand now, that he was a con man. It's even hard to say that out loud. He was, though. For years, Stascha felt torn between her distaste for Riley's behavior and her love for the
他没有回来。一年多来，斯塔莎不知道他在哪里。最终她发现他住在离弗雷斯诺大约一小时路程的地方。他们重新联系上了，但一切都变了。她现在看清了他到底是谁。他美化了骗子的生活。他美化了诈骗犯的生活。我现在明白了，他是个骗子。甚至很难大声说出来。但他确实是。多年来，斯塔莎感到在对莱利行为的厌恶和对他的爱之间挣扎，
dad who made her smoke rings and took her to the brown derby. By the mid-80s, Stascha had left Porteville. A few years later, Riley returned to the town and played the role of the old cowboy musician. Stasha mainly stayed in touch by phone as the year has passed. One day in 2008, she got a call. Her dad had taken a fall in his home. And he ended up in the hospital after being alone on the floor for days. And I called him and he goes, honey, I know I'm gonna die. But he was so sweet.
那个给她吐烟圈、带她去“棕色德比”的父亲。到80年代中期，斯塔莎离开了波特维尔。几年后，莱利回到了镇上，扮演老牛仔音乐家的角色。随着岁月的流逝，斯塔莎主要通过电话与他保持联系。2008年的一天，她接到了一个电话。她父亲在家里摔倒了。他在地板上独自躺了几天后被送进了医院。我给他打电话，他说，亲爱的，我知道我要死了。但他太甜了。
I can't talk about that, but he said he loved me, and that he was proud of me. It was like beautiful. Riley rallied and moved to a nursing home. When stasha visited, he seemed agitated. And he goes, you don't, you don't know what it's like in here. I thought he meant the nursing home because three beds that I had the TV on, it was loud. I go, what, the nursing home? Because no, you don't, you don't know what it's like in here and here and he was pointing to his head. And I go, what, what are you talking about?
我不能谈论那个，但他说了他爱我，他为我感到骄傲。那真是太美了。莱利振作起来，搬进了一家疗养院。当斯塔莎去探望时，他显得很不安。他说，你不知道这里是什么样子。我以为他指的是疗养院，因为有三张床，电视开着，声音很大。我说，什么，疗养院？因为不，你不知道这里是什么样子，他指着自己的头。我说，什么，你在说什么？
He goes, I'm, I'm, I'm flashing back on all the things I did. And I did some bad things. Stasha tried to comfort him, but in retrospect, she wishes she'd ask a question. What bad things? Tell me about those. What were the bad things? Maybe if you tell me about them, you'll feel better, because I'm wondering what all he
他说，我，我，我正在回想我做过的所有事情。我做了一些坏事。斯塔莎试图安慰他，但回想起来，她希望自己问了一个问题。什么坏事？告诉我那些。坏事是什么？也许如果你告诉我，你会感觉好一点，因为我想知道他所有
would have told me. But he lived for a little bit in the nursing home. That was the last time that I visited him. After Riley died, Stasha wanted the world to remember her father correctly. So she made sure his obituary included not just his real name, but all the pseudonyms he was known to use. Dick Scott, Hickey Free, Clim Hawley, Johnny Rebel, Dickson Hall, Gene Gilmore, Dick Gleason, Paul Lester, Richard Alexander, Albert Riley, Joe Graham, Richard James Hawley, after Riley died, Stasha had his body cremated. For a long time, she carried his ashes around
会告诉我的事情。但他还在疗养院住了一段时间。那是我最后一次探望他。莱利去世后，斯塔莎希望世界能正确地记住她的父亲。所以她确保他的讣告不仅包括他的真名，还包括他众所周知的笔名。迪克·斯科特、希基·弗里、克莱姆·霍利、约翰尼·雷贝尔、迪克森·霍尔、吉恩·吉尔摩、迪克·格里森、保罗·莱斯特、理查德·亚历山大、阿尔伯特·莱利、乔·格雷厄姆、理查德·詹姆斯·霍利。莱利去世后，斯塔莎将他的遗体火化了。很长一段时间，她带着他的骨灰
with her. She'd scatter a handful here or there, which seemed fitting for a drifter. There wasn't much in the Riley Shepherd estate. estate. Stasha packed up some of his letters, a cookbook he'd written for her, and various other papers. But his life's work, the encyclopedia he'd He'd left that to someone else. And in here, we find row upon row of collection boxes on the shelf. By the time I got to the basement of the Library of Congress, I figured I knew everything I needed to know about Riley Shepard. He was a crook, a con man, a bad husband, an unreliable father. So as folkloreist Steve Winnick pulls out the Richard Riley Shepard collection from the stacks,
随身携带。她会在这里或那里撒一把，这对一个流浪者来说似乎很合适。莱利·谢泼德的遗产里没剩下多少东西。斯塔莎收拾了一些他的信件、一本他为她写的食谱和其他各种文件。但他毕生的心血，那部百科全书，他留给了别人。在这里，我们发现书架上摆放着一排排的收藏盒。当我到达国会图书馆的地下室时，我想我已经知道关于莱利·谢泼德的一切了。他是个骗子、诈骗犯、糟糕的丈夫、不可靠的父亲。所以当民俗学家史蒂夫·威尼克从书架上取出理查德·莱利·谢泼德的收藏时，
I'm not holding my breath. Nobody's really used this collection very much, so it's simply, you know, been there waiting for you, really. Up in his office, Hagrid, aka Folklorist Steve Winnick spreads out the papers from the Richard Reilly Shepherd collection on a table. He picks up a letter. The date of this letter is September 7th 1976. More than four decades ago Reilly wrote this letter to the registrar of copyrights. Stascha was 11 years old. So he was working on things, he was working on, I didn't know what. In the letter, Riley asks for the forms he'll need to copyright and encyclopedia.
我并没有屏住呼吸。真的没几个人用过这个收藏，所以它只是，你知道，一直待在那里等着你，真的。在办公室里，海格，也就是民俗学家史蒂夫·威尼克把理查德·莱利·谢泼德收藏的纸张铺在桌子上。他拿起一封信。这封信的日期是1976年9月7日。四十多年前，莱利写了这封信给版权登记处。斯塔莎当时11岁。所以他在做一些事情，他在做，我不知道是什么。在信中，莱利要求获得他为百科全书申请版权所需的表格。
He adds a long post script. He says perhaps someone in the Library of Congress would be interested in the following. Over the past 16 years, I alphabetically indexed more than 43,000 titles of songs, including published versions and variants in English, French, Spanish, etc., all of which have enjoyed a folk-type tradition within the borders of the United States and Canada. All the titles, he continues, have been alphabetically cross-indexed and cross-referenced, with the titles of books they appeared in, along with the editors and publishers. Each reference is clearly coded, so that practically every folk song relative to the United States,
他加了一个很长的附言。他说也许国会图书馆的某个人会对以下内容感兴趣。在过去的16年中，我按字母顺序索引了超过43,000首歌曲的标题，包括已出版的版本和变体，涵盖英语、法语、西班牙语等，所有这些都在美国和加拿大的边界内享有民俗传统。他继续说，所有的标题都已按字母顺序交叉索引和交叉引用，并附有它们出现的书籍标题，以及编辑和出版商。每个参考资料都经过清晰编码，以便与美国相关的几乎每一首民俗歌曲，
plus all its known versions and variants, can be easily located. You may be interested to learn that the 43,000 titles are clearly the outgrowth of only 4,000 songs, texts and tunes. He ends the letter this way. I know only one thing. I am the only person in the world with this amount of cross-index, cross-referenced musical material. Unfortunately, I do not own or have access to a computer in which to feed the information. Perhaps the Library of Congress can offer suggestions.
加上所有已知的版本和变体，都可以轻松定位。你可能会有兴趣知道，这43,000个标题显然只是4,000首歌曲、文本和曲调的产物。他以这种方式结束了这封信。我只知道一件事。我是世界上唯一拥有如此多交叉索引、交叉引用音乐资料的人。不幸的是，我没有拥有或无法使用计算机来输入这些信息。也许国会图书馆可以提供建议。
Riley wanted to get his encyclopedia to a wider audience. The chief archivist at the time wrote back and offered the names of potential publishers. He also said he'd like to see some of Riley's work. So Riley sent in the samples that the library now holds. In a follow-up letter, Riley explained how his indexing system worked. Each title is followed by the first line or lines of the song and or versions thereof.
莱利想让他的百科全书获得更广泛的受众。当时的首席档案管理员回信并提供了潜在出版商的名字。他还说他想看看莱利的一些作品。所以莱利寄来了图书馆现在持有的样本。在后续信件中，莱利解释了他的索引系统是如何工作的。每个标题后面都跟着歌曲的第一行或几行，和/或其版本。
And this, by the source, example. Goose hangs high, the Civil War Ballad. It deals with Lee's invasion of Pennsylvania and the Battle of Gettysburg. As Steve Winnick sifts through the materials, he slowly grasps the enormity of the project. So he's got 43,000 individual sheets or two sheets of paper however long it takes
以及这个，按来源，例如。《鹅高高挂》，内战民谣。它涉及李将军入侵宾夕法尼亚州和葛底斯堡战役。当史蒂夫·威尼克筛选这些材料时，他慢慢领会了这个项目的巨大规模。所以他有43,000张单独的纸或两张纸，无论需要多长时间
that he's got to then sort into 4,000 categories. And then in addition to that, he has to cross reference each of those with all of the places that they've been published. So, there's an enormous number of cross-references within this book that he had to do by hand without the ability to electronically associate one item with another. What Riley Shepard had been working on since 1960 was a monumental accounting of some 200 years of American folk music. It involved a search of nearly every available documentary source. Riley had obtained rare books at great expense, including many that were out of print. He had collated thousands of songs and
他必须将它们分类为4,000个类别。然后除此之外，他还必须将每一个与它们出版的所有地方进行交叉引用。所以，这本书中有大量的交叉引用，他必须手工完成，而没有能力以电子方式将一个项目与另一个项目关联起来。莱利·谢泼德自1960年以来一直在研究的是对大约200年美国民俗音乐的纪念性记录。它涉及对几乎所有可用文献来源的搜索。莱利不惜重金获得了稀有书籍，包括许多绝版书。他整理了数千首歌曲，
organized them according to their provenance discovering common roots and pathways that linked different musical traditions together. Since he did not have a computer, almost no one did at the time, he did everything by hand, cross referencing song lyrics and musical notations and historical footnotes. Crazy as it sounds, the entire system lived largely inside his own head. By the point he wrote to the Library of Congress, he had spent nearly two decades trying to put down on paper what was in his head. Even as his life fell apart around him, and many of his closest friends and relatives came to think of him as a crook.
并根据它们的来源组织它们，发现了将不同音乐传统联系在一起的共同根源和路径。由于他没有电脑，当时几乎没有人有，他手工完成了所有事情，交叉引用歌词、乐谱和历史脚注。听起来很疯狂，整个系统主要存在于他自己的脑海中。在他写信给国会图书馆时，他已经花了近二十年时间试图把他脑子里的东西写在纸上。即使他的生活在他周围分崩离析，他许多最亲近的朋友和亲戚也开始认为他是个骗子。
At the time, as far as I know, no one had attempted something this ambitious in terms of indexing all the songs in America. Riley Shepard, a man with a fifth grade education, an occasional writer of porn, a con man and hustler, had attempted to create something that would require years of effort by a team of PhD archivists and a small army of researchers. The fact of the attempt,
当时，据我所知，没有人尝试过在索引美国所有歌曲方面做如此雄心勃勃的事情。莱利·谢泼德，一个只有五年级教育程度的人，偶尔写色情作品的作家，一个骗子和诈骗犯，试图创造出需要博士档案管理员团队和一小群研究人员多年努力才能完成的东西。尝试的事实，
I think, is actually a significant fact in the history of folksong scholarship in the United States. And it's actually something almost nobody knows about. I wouldn't know about it if you hadn't brought it to my attention. And, you know, I've studied this for quite a number of years. I asked Steve to choose a song and explain how Riley had classified it. So he opened volume three, ran his finger down pages filled with typerate entries.
我认为，实际上是美国民俗歌曲研究史上一个重要的事实。而且这实际上是几乎没人知道的事情。如果你没有引起我的注意，我不会知道它。而且，你知道，我已经研究这个很多年了。我请史蒂夫选一首歌，解释莱利是如何分类它的。所以他打开了第三卷，手指滑过写满打字条目的页面。
So I'll go to one that I'm quite familiar with. This is Holloway Joe, which is a C-shanty. And it says, this is a short drag or short haul shanty. It was taken from British sailors and American eyes, which means political references were eliminated from the text. American sailors preferred to concentrate on girls. For example, the British sailors sang. Louis was the king of France before the revolution,
所以我去一个我很熟悉的。这是《霍洛威·乔》，这是一首海员号子。它说，这是一首短拖或短途号子。它取自英国水手和美国水手，这意味着政治参考从文本中被删除了。美国水手更喜欢专注于女孩。例如，英国水手唱道。路易是法国国王，在革命之前，
but Louis got his head cut off, which spoiled his constitution. American sailors had more important things to sing about and changed the words to, once I had a German girl, but she was change the words to once I had a German girl But she was fat and lazy then I had an Irish girl. She damn near drove me crazy The shanti dates back to around the second half of the 18th century Though only in England in the USA it dates back to the years following the word 1812 For other English and American versions see the works listed below and then He gives a long list of books in
但路易被砍了头，这破坏了他的宪法。美国水手有更重要的事情要唱，把歌词改成了，曾经我有一个德国女孩，但她很胖很懒，然后我有一个爱尔兰女孩。她差点把我逼疯。这首号子可以追溯到18世纪下半叶，虽然只在英国，在美国它追溯到1812年战争后的几年。对于其他英语和美国版本，请参阅下面列出的作品，然后他给出了一个很长的书籍列表，
which this song appears. And he actually gives you the music for the song as well? In for many of the songs he does yes he does have music for Hallow H.O. as well. How does the tune of this song go? Do you remember it? When I was a little boy it's all my mother told me way all the way, all the way, Joe. Now, if I didn't kiss the girls, my lips would all grow moldy away, all the way, all the way, Joe. I have to say the impressive thing is you closed the book and you did that. This was all in your head, too. Yeah, it was.
其中出现了这首歌。他实际上也给了你这首歌的乐谱？对于许多歌曲，他确实有，是的，他也有《霍洛威·乔》的乐谱。这首歌的曲调是怎么样的？你还记得吗？当我还是个小男孩时，我母亲告诉我，一路，一路，乔。现在，如果我不亲吻女孩，我的嘴唇就会发霉，一路，一路，一路，乔。我不得不说令人印象深刻的是你合上书就做到了。这也在你的脑子里，对吧？是的，确实。
In 1979, three years after his first letter, Riley got in touch again with a library of Congress. He said he'd been unable to find a publisher. And so he writes, Dear Mr. Hickerson, in case you don't remember, I have enclosed a photocopy of your letter to me dated July 8, 1977. First, I want to thank you for your suggestions and the addresses of possible publishers. I followed up, no funds are available for a work such as mine, though they are interested in what I have done and would appreciate a copy of the folk song finder and index. It
1979年，在他第一封信三年后，莱利再次与国会图书馆联系。他说他一直没能找到出版商。于是他写道，亲爱的希克森先生，如果你不记得了，我附上了你1977年7月8日给我写的信的复印件。首先，我要感谢你的建议和可能出版商的地址。我跟进了，没有资金可用于像我这样的作品，尽管他们对我的工作感兴趣，并会感谢一份《民俗歌曲查找器和索引》。它
is of voluminous work, so I can understand the reluctance of a publisher to undertake the expense of its publication. So here I am, back to you again. It was an act of desperation. If you were our serious about the library reaching some agreement with me, I am ready to proceed. My problem is this, I don't know what to ask for in terms of financial remuneration to myself. I do know that I cannot ask as much as I have spent in terms of time, work, and money, but I would like to recoup at least some of my own expenditures, if not payment for my work and time.
是一部卷帙浩繁的作品，所以我能理解出版商承担出版费用的不情愿。所以现在，我又回到你这里了。这是一种绝望的行为。如果你对图书馆与我达成某种协议是认真的，我已经准备好继续了。我的问题是这个，我不知道在经济报酬方面该要求什么。我知道我不能要求我所花费的时间、工作和金钱那么多，但我希望能收回至少一部分我自己的支出，如果不是为我的工作和时间支付报酬的话。
In fact, I must recoup some of what I have spent because I have already signed a lease on a small farm and house in Porterville, California, and expect to move there in approximately six weeks. As I am, as they say, in the country music field, flat-busted. Riley never got what he was seeking. What he was asking was a significant outlay of money that I just think the library couldn't afford at the time or couldn't, you know, a portion to that project because, as he says in the correspondence, in addition to these volumes, there are 54 other volumes of this book. 54 other
事实上，我必须收回我花费的一部分，因为我已经签署了加利福尼亚州波特维尔一个小农场和房子的租约，并预计在大约六周内搬到那里。正如他们所说，在乡村音乐领域，我身无分文。莱利从未得到他所寻求的。他所要求的是一笔巨大的资金支出，我认为图书馆当时负担不起，或者无法，你知道，分配给那个项目，因为正如他在信中所说，除了这些卷宗，还有54卷这本书。54卷
volumes. After nearly two decades of painstaking work came the final indignity. Rejection. Yeah, I think he was an early casualty, you might say, of the switch from published books, that is paper books, to computer documentation. And he's aware of this. I mean, because he talks about how it would be great if he could put this into a computer. Would you say that Rhymeshap was a genius? He was a genius, I think. It's very impressive to see the amount of work that he did on this. And he also had that sort of crazy perseverance that you have to have.
其他卷。经过近二十年的艰苦工作，最后是侮辱。拒绝。是的，我认为他是一个早期受害者，你可以说是从出版书籍，也就是纸质书，转向计算机文档的受害者。他意识到了这一点。我的意思是，因为他谈到了如果他能把这个输入电脑会很棒。你会说莱利·谢泼德是个天才吗？我认为他是个天才。看到他在这个项目上所做的工作量是非常令人印象深刻的。而且他还有那种你必须具备的疯狂毅力。
So that's a whole other kind of genius. Here is a really amazing part. Riley continued to work on the Encyclopedia for the next 25 years. I mean, it is the case that since he would have sent this to the library in 1979, a lot more versions of traditional songs were published. So if he were trying to keep this book complete, he would have to continue to update it year after year. One of the interesting things is I'm not sure his family actually fully understands what he has done.
所以那是另一种天才。这是一个非常令人惊奇的部分。莱利在接下来的25年里继续研究百科全书。我的意思是，事实是，自从他在1979年把它寄给图书馆以来，更多版本的传统歌曲被出版了。所以如果他试图保持这本书的完整，他将不得不年复一年地继续更新它。有趣的事情之一是，我不确定他的家人是否真正完全理解他所做的事情。
When I spoke with his daughter, Starsha, she just thought her dad was sort of obsessed with this project that never seemed to go anywhere, that never seemed to end, that just grew infinitely. And over the years, she had in fact heard from people whom he had borrowed money from and taken money from. And her impression of her dad is not a very positive impression. And in some way speaking with you, I get a different picture of this man.
当我与他的女儿斯塔莎交谈时，她只是觉得她父亲似乎沉迷于这个永远看不到尽头、永远无法完成、只会无限膨胀的项目。多年来，她确实从那些被他借钱或拿钱的人那里听说过一些事。她对父亲的印象并不太好。但在某种程度上，通过与你交谈，我对这个男人有了不同的看法。
Well, I think that all scholars, and particularly folk song scholars, have something of the Riley Shepherd in them, we would like to spend all our time and all our life immersed in the texts and tunes of folk songs. We just can't manage it because we have lives. So the amount of yourself that you're willing to give to that might vary for different people, but we certainly have sympathy for someone who gave so much of himself to it. I don't know if you're familiar with the anthropologist Arnold Van Henepp. He's the person who popularized the term rights of passage. And Van Henepp wrote a piece called The Research Project, or Folkler Without End.
嗯，我认为所有的学者，尤其是民歌学者，身上都有点莱利·谢泼德的影子，我们都想把所有的时间和生命都沉浸在民歌的歌词和曲调中。我们只是做不到，因为我们还要生活。所以你愿意为之投入多少精力因人而异，但我们当然同情那些为此倾注了如此多心血的人。不知道你是否熟悉人类学家阿诺德·范·根内普。他就是推广“通过仪式”这一术语的人。范·根内普写过一篇名为《研究项目》或《无尽的民俗学》的文章。
And it was about a person who decided to write the definitive work on the evil eye. And he went to his Carol in the library and he began getting all the books about the evil eye and he compiled all of the references that he could find. And he took it to his advisor and his advisor says, this is a great start, but there's still other cultures and there's ancient Greek and Roman sources that you should look at. So he goes back and he works on those. This continues for years and years, and eventually this man dies at his Carol in the library, and nobody quite remembers what he was doing there.
那是关于一个人决定撰写关于“邪眼”的权威著作。他去了图书馆的阅览室，开始收集所有关于邪眼的资料，并汇编了他能找到的所有参考文献。他把这些拿给导师看，导师说，这是一个很好的开始，但还有其他文化，以及古希腊和罗马的资料你应该看看。于是他回去继续研究这些。这种情况持续了多年，最终这个人死在了图书馆的阅览室里，没人记得他到底在做什么。
That's kind of the impression that you get of Riley Shepherd. But it turned out there was someone next to Riley in his final days as he labored away in his carol. Before he collapsed and was sent to the hospital, Riley was living in a small house on D Street in Portofil. He was in rough shape. I thought you know he's a little bit disheveled. But Steve Ancelin, a Porteville native, says once you got to know Riley, he grew on you. It was Steve's father, Ted, who really knew Riley. Ted was a retired insurance agent and former Porteville mayor. Steve says his dad and Riley bonded over a shared love of music.
这就是你对莱利·谢泼德的印象。但事实证明，在莱利生命的最后日子里，当他在阅览室里辛勤工作时，他身边还有一个人。在晕倒并被送往医院之前，莱利住在波特维尔D街的一所小房子里。他的状况很糟糕。我以为你知道，他有点邋遢。但波特维尔本地人史蒂夫·安塞林说，一旦你了解了莱利，你就会喜欢上他。真正了解莱利的是史蒂夫的父亲泰德。泰德是一位退休的保险代理人，也是波特维尔的前市长。史蒂夫说他父亲和莱利因对音乐的共同热爱而结缘。
They would just sit and listen to country western music, the old country western music, not the new stuff. They were friends. They were also business partners. They wrote songs together, they recorded a few songs together. Mainly though, they worked on Riley's encyclopedia. Kat saw the genius in it. They spent hours and hours and hours just collecting all the material and then categorizing it. Steve says Riley was still consumed by the project.
他们会坐在一起听乡村西部音乐，那种老派的乡村西部音乐，而不是新出的那些。他们是朋友，也是商业伙伴。他们一起写歌，一起录制了几首歌。但主要是，他们致力于莱利的百科全书。泰德看到了其中的天才之处。他们花了无数个小时收集所有材料，然后进行分类。史蒂夫说莱利仍然沉迷于这个项目。
Well, he had music spread all over. I mean, he had tables and chairs and floor and everything, and he had had this music spread out, and he was trying to get it in some sort of chronological order, and by the artist, he was trying to get the artist with the song, and he would have the song, and then he would have the artist. He was trying to get the artist with the song and he would have the song and then he would have the artist. And so he would try to cross reference all of those. So it was a labor of love. I'll tell you that, but he was, he just, no, I haven't got
嗯，他的音乐资料到处都是。我是说，桌子上、椅子上、地板上，到处都是。他把这些音乐摊开，试图按时间顺序排列，按艺术家排列，他试图把艺术家和歌曲对应起来，他有歌，然后有艺术家。他试图把艺术家和歌曲对应起来，他有歌，然后有艺术家。所以他试图对所有这些进行交叉引用。所以这是一项爱的劳动。我告诉你，但他就是，他只是，不，我没时间做那个。
time for that. I don't want to eat. I just, I got to get this done. This is important. And so he would just, I got to get this done. I, this is, this is important. And so he would just, he, he was funny. Stephen's father both felt they were in the presence of an extraordinary human being. Riley Shepard was, was a master. He, he did a lot of things, but he was quite a, quite a, quite a master. Steve's father willingly gave his time to the project, and he gave money, plenty of it.
我不想吃饭。我只是，我必须完成这个。这很重要。所以他会，我必须完成这个。我，这，这很重要。所以他会，他，他很有趣。史蒂夫的父亲都觉得他们是在一位非凡的人面前。莱利·谢泼德是，是一位大师。他，他做了很多事情，但他确实是一位，一位，一位大师。史蒂夫的父亲心甘情愿地为这个项目贡献了时间，还贡献了金钱，很多钱。
Steve says after Riley died, Stasya got in touch. She was concerned that her dad had conned his dad. But Steve says the money wasn't important. The money doesn't mean anything as far as I saw the enjoyment that it brought to my dad. Raleigh left his life's work, the encyclopedia of folk music, to his friend, Ted Enslyn. They were 40 boxes. Ted stored them in his old insurance office, and that's where they sat for years. I kept asking dad, you know, what are you going to do with these Dad? What are you going to do with these?
史蒂夫说莱利去世后，斯塔莎联系了他。她担心她父亲骗了他父亲。但史蒂夫说钱并不重要。据我所知，钱并不意味着什么，重要的是它给我父亲带来的快乐。莱利把他毕生的心血——民俗音乐百科全书——留给了他的朋友泰德·安塞林。那是40个箱子。泰德把它们存放在他旧的保险办公室里，它们在那里放了很多年。我一直问爸爸，你知道，你打算怎么处理这些？爸爸，你打算怎么处理这些？
And he says, he says there were a lot of money. And I said, well, I know about what are you going to do with them. Ted never did anything with them. He was old and suffering from dementia. Instead, he just relived his friendship with Riley. After Riley died, my dad had a little record player in his office, and he would put on a lot of Riley's country western music. It was fun while it lasted, but it didn't last long. And he just enjoyed Riley, enjoyed his friendship. When Ted Enselin died, Steve gave the encyclopedia to another man in town who happened to be a country music songwriter.
他说，他说那值很多钱。我说，好吧，我知道，但你打算怎么处理它们。泰德从来没有处理过它们。他老了，患有痴呆症。相反，他只是重温了他与莱利的友谊。莱利去世后，我父亲办公室里有一个小唱片机，他会放很多莱利的乡村西部音乐。那段时光很美好，但没持续多久。他只是享受莱利，享受他们的友谊。泰德·安塞林去世后，史蒂夫把百科全书给了镇上的另一个人，那个人恰好是一位乡村音乐词曲作者。
Steve says he was told the pages of carefully indexed entries were eventually split up. Some were shipped off to Nashville and some to the Bakowen's Museum in Bakersfield, California. Other copies are also floating around. Not long ago, Stascher says a couple who'd invested in Riles and Cyclopedia got in touch. They were willing to sell their copy to her for $500. She bought it. She says it's huge. Well, it's weird to see the whole thing and how much work he actually put into it. Because after I realized how much my father fabricated on various things from, you know, he just was a compulsive liar.
史蒂夫说他被告知那些精心索引的页面最终被拆分了。一些被运往纳什维尔，一些被运往加利福尼亚州贝克斯菲尔德的巴科文博物馆。其他副本也在流传。不久前，斯塔莎说一对投资了莱利百科全书的夫妇联系了她。他们愿意以500美元的价格把他们的副本卖给她。她买了。她说这太庞大了。嗯，看到整个东西以及他实际上投入了多少工作，这很奇怪。因为在我意识到我父亲在各种事情上编造了多少东西之后，你知道，他只是一个强迫性撒谎者。
Sometimes you would make things up and I couldn't figure out why, why did you lie about that? Why didn't you brag about the songs you actually wrote? Why did you say you wrote blue Christmas or whatever? And so I became kind of jaded and I began to think that maybe the whole project to the Encyclopedia was not even worth thinking about it all. I loved my dad but I kind of rolled my eyes whenever whenever I thought about these projects, because so much, so much smoke and mirrors around it. Broken heart will never man. It was fun while it lasted, but it didn't last long. You left people so mudd in due time. In the conversation near the end of his life, the one recorded by music historian Kevin Koffee, Raleigh Shepard doesn't sound bitter or frustrated. He sounds like a man still
有时你会编造一些事情，我无法理解为什么，你为什么要撒谎？你为什么不吹嘘你真正写的歌？你为什么要说你写了《蓝色圣诞节》之类的歌？所以我变得有点厌倦了，我开始认为也许整个百科全书项目根本不值得考虑。我爱我的父亲，但每当我想到这些项目时，我都会翻白眼，因为周围有太多的烟雾和镜子。破碎的心永远不会……那段时光很美好，但没持续多久。你让人们在适当的时候感到困惑。在他生命尽头的一次谈话中，由音乐历史学家凯文·科菲录制的那次，莱利·谢泼德听起来并不痛苦或沮丧。他听起来像是一个仍然
doing what he loves, honoring the music he had learned as a boy, trying to preserve it. In fact, he told Kevin, there were still plenty of songs and music that were left in him. I'm writing one now. I've got a call to the over you get. The more it's going to cost you to do the thing you did when you were young. When an old man's in love, he just thinks he's in love. He's not cooking with gas. He's just warming it over. He's on like that. Songs and novels are filled with stories about people with great obsessions. We have strong opinions about such people, when they succeed, when they produce the Taj Mahal or Hamlet or the iPhone, we hail the obsessions that built the monuments of this world.
做着他热爱的事情的人，纪念他儿时学过的音乐，试图保存它。事实上，他告诉凯文，他身上还有很多歌曲和音乐。我正在写一首。我得说，你越老，做你年轻时做过的事情成本就越高。当一个老人恋爱时，他只是认为自己在恋爱。他不是在用燃气做饭，他只是在加热剩菜。他就是那样。歌曲和小说里充满了关于那些有巨大执念的人的故事。我们对这样的人有强烈的看法，当他们成功时，当他们创造出泰姬陵、哈姆雷特或iPhone时，我们赞美那些建造了世界纪念碑的执念。
When we count the collateral damage that people with obsessions leave in their wake, especially when those obsessions only produce the unreadable tom on the evil eye, or an unpublishable encyclopedia on folk music, obsessions start to look like folly. on folk music. Obsessions start to look like folly. Trouble is, you usually do not know whether an obsession is a great quest or a great folly. Until it's over. This week's show was produced by Jenny Schmidt and Parth Shah and edited by Tara Boyle. Special thanks to Ashley Messenger. Our team includes Raina Cohen, Laura Correll, Thomas Liu, Kat Schuchnecht and Lushik Wabba.
当我们计算那些有执念的人留下的附带损害时，尤其是当这些执念只产生了一本关于邪眼的可读性极差的大部头，或者一本无法出版的民俗音乐百科全书时，执念就开始看起来像愚蠢了。问题是，你通常不知道一个执念是伟大的追求还是巨大的愚蠢。直到它结束。本周的节目由珍妮·施密特和帕斯·沙制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。特别感谢阿什利·梅森杰。我们的团队包括雷娜·科恩、劳拉·科雷尔、托马斯·刘、凯特·舒赫内希特和卢希克·瓦巴。
Engineering support from Patrick Boyd and Andy Huthar. Our unsung heroes today are Hugh Williams and Radio Orkney in Scotland. One of the difficulties we faced with this episode was finding audio of Riley Shepard's voice. Happily, we discovered that music historian Kevin Coffey still had tape of the interview he did with Riley. Our next challenge was connecting with Kevin, who lives in the Orkney Islands. Hugh Williams and his team at Radio Orkney were able to help us record an interview. We are so grateful.
工程支持来自帕特里克·博伊德和安迪·胡萨尔。我们今天的无名英雄是休·威廉姆斯和苏格兰奥克尼电台。我们在制作这一集时面临的困难之一是寻找莱利·谢泼德的声音音频。幸运的是，我们发现音乐历史学家凯文·科菲仍然保留着他与莱利采访的录音带。我们的下一个挑战是联系住在奥克尼群岛的凯文。休·威廉姆斯和他在奥克尼电台的团队能够帮助我们录制采访。我们非常感激。
For more Hidden Brain, you can find us on Facebook and Twitter. To see a slight show of photos of Riley Shepard, visit our website, npr.org, slash Hidden Brain. If this episode spoke to you, please take one moment to share it with a friend. A quick update. After this episode first aired, hillbilly music fans came together to try to find the many boxes of Rylees and Cyclopedia. The boxes were found and Stascha delivered them to the Internet Archive in San Francisco. The Encyclopedia is now online. I'm Shankar Vedanthantham and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上找到我们。要查看莱利·谢泼德的照片幻灯片，请访问我们的网站npr.org，斜杠Hidden Brain。如果这一集触动了你，请花一点时间与朋友分享。快速更新。在这一集首次播出后，乡村音乐迷们聚集在一起，试图寻找莱利的百科全书的许多箱子。箱子被找到了，斯塔莎把它们送到了旧金山的互联网档案馆。百科全书现在可以在线查阅了。我是尚卡尔·维丹坦，这是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。